let's bring in Congressman August fluger
a republican from Texas also a member of
the House Homeland Security committee
Congressman good morning to you uh your
committee did the investigation uh tell
us why you've decided to move forward
with these articles of impeachment
against the DHS
secretary well thank you for having me
and I take no pleasure in talking about
this because what we actually want is
just a secure border uh but when you
look at the egregious nature of what
this Administration has done under the
leadership of secretary my who took an
oath of office by the way to protect and
defend the Constitution you're talking
over 8 million people illegally in this
country over 300 who matched the terror
watch list that we know about a 100,000
deaths from fentel and so our articles
of impeachment by the way which I think
could have been done as early as last
year uh and even before because we've
been talking about this for so long
they're very simple the articles are
very simple article one says that
there's a willful and systemic refusal
to follow the law that's the immigration
and National nationality act in article
two says that there's a breach of public
trust what you just heard those two are
very simple but they factually outline
the refusal of secretary mayorcas to
keep our country St safe and article
four of the Constitution very clearly
says it is the federal government's
responsibility to protect all states
from an invasion that's exactly what's
going on here we do have an invasion and
they've refused to keep us safe Congress
walk us through the timing because Peter
mentioned at the end of his report that
speaker Johnson wants to vote on it soon
does this have to pass out of a
committee or is it ready for a floor
vote where do you see this
going that that's right we will actually
the homeland security committee get
together on Tuesday um and and we will
Mark the Articles up so that means that
there could be um you know probably
language change that doesn't really
change the the two articles that I just
mentioned but talking about about the
exact uh ways in which the secretary
violated the law and the ways that he
misled Congress we're talking about
Detention of illegal aliens the parole
of illegal aliens his Mass Catch and
Release scheme that's going to happen on
Tuesday and then we expect to vote on
the house floor hopefully as early as as
Wednesday or Thursday that will be up to
the speaker and the
leadership Congress I'm just looking
here I I think we might have some of
this we can put up on the screen um I'm
not sure so I'm asking the producers at
the same time key quotes from the draft
um of what you guys have put together
and you did lay out the various stages
where you say mayorcas has failed the
law to to implement the law as passed by
Congress what this seems to come down to
is a policy by an Administration
embraced and then executed by mayoras
but Embrace that is in violation of
congressional law and some of what you
described is up on the screen now
article k um of the impeachment drafts
Alejandro mayorcas knowingly made false
statements this is about what he said to
Congress that the border secure the
border is no less secure than it was
previously that the border is closed and
the DHS has operational control of the
Border that's pointing out um lies that
you're holding he he told
Congress that's exactly right and you
know it's just so egregious the numbers
are egregious the impact on our
communities not just Texas I mean I'm
sitting 2 hours from Eagle Pass right
now doing this interview but it's not
just the numbers it's not just the
impact on Texas it's the impact on every
single state and then his attempt to
mislead not just Congress but the
American public in saying that they have
operational control of the border which
we all knew from the very first day that
they were in office was false you know
just a couple of weeks ago we had a
hearing secretary my orcus was sitting
next to director Ray and I asked
director Ray a simple question I said
are there people who match the terror
watch list that you know about who've
entered this country that are still at
large and he said yes and then I asked
my orcus who was sitting directly next
to him I said is it your policy to
detain anyone who matches the terror
watch list and he couldn't answer that
question in the affirmative this is why
we're going through the impeachment
trial because obviously somebody who
matches a terror watch list should
immediately be detained should
immediately be deported or done you know
something needs to be done done with
them to protect the American citizens
from some sort of terror act it's that
type of behavior that has happened for
three plus years and resulted in almost
9 million people illegally in our
country many of whom have have uh
desires to do bad things in this country
criminally or on a terror aspect right
we just don't know who they are but what
would you say to somebody who says your
fight shouldn't be with Alejandra
mayorcas it should be with President
Biden and he's just following
ERS well it's a great question and I'll
tell you that Jamie comr and Jim Jordan
have that fight with him right now
they're looking at what the president
has done and that case is actually much
bigger than just protecting the border
so right now our Focus has to be on a
secretary who has taken an oath to
protect and defend the Constitution and
and I guarantee you that uh chairman
comr and chairman Jordan are looking at
the president and many other aspects of
his failure to keep our country safe
here's one more quote from uh
impeachment articles again these are
brand new uh we just received them here
uh at Fox and Friends uh it says this
throughout his tenure as Secretary of
Homeland Security Alejandro n mayorcas
has repeatedly violated laws enacted by
Congress regarding immigration and
border security in large part because of
his unlawful conduct millions of aliens
have illegally entered the United States
on an annual basis with many unlawfully
remaining in the United States his
refusal to obey the law is not only an
offense against the separation of powers
in the con Constitution of the United
States it also threatens our national
security uh you you've reiterated a lot
of that as well you know we've heard
Democrats speak a lot more about the
Border a lot of it's because an election
year is coming do you think any
Democrats will Vote for This impeachment
or do you think this will be almost all
Republicans that's a great question and
I sure hope they do I hope that they are
Democrats from Texas especially those
that are on the border that know the
damage that's being done to our
communities that will have the courage
to stand up this is not uh just a policy
fight this is an actual refusal to
enforce the laws that are already on the
books these Democrats know that I really
hope that they have the courage to do
the right thing because it has hurt just
it's hurt every American not just
Republicans this has hurt Democrats too
that is why you see many Democrats in
South Texas and along the border region
switching from the Democrat Party to the
Republican party because they don't
trust this Administration and they don't
trust Alejandro
mayorcas all right Congressman August
fluger of Texas thanks so much for being
with us this morning as these articles
of impeachment are released uh we're
glad to have you to highlight exactly
what's been done thank you so much thank
you sir I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kill me
and I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis